- This shit's binary,
either you're a good person
or you're a bad person,
either you got talent
or you don't.
If you're a good person and you got talent
you win.
If you're the other part, you lost.
(intense music)
I'm in L.A. making some shit happen today.
Headed to the airport in a little bit.
And headed to Australia,
I'm giving four talks
in three days and, being
back in New York by Friday.
So, fucking, I'm grinding
man, fucking working out here.
(gentle piano music)
Bye.
Dude, I'm like a totally
different man right now.
Vlog, morning, I don't know,
you know what actually,
dude please chop up
like the three or four highlights in here.
What's going on my phone?
Faster. Maybe the cloud.
Dude it's running totally different.
I'm pumped.
(deep breath)
There's nothing like your
phone working properly.
I thought the X was like a piece of shit.
- [Filmer] Dude.
- Can you throw that phone on the ground.
But something got fucked up with my,
my iCloud backup and like,
playing with it right now,
compared to the last 24 hours is like,
or 36 hours is incredible.
I just feel so happy. Yay.
Ten minutes late for a
meeting. I hate that feeling.
Fuck.
(hip hop music)
Hey Babin, you didn't
pick a winner for the,
- I went through some people
but I didn't find anyone.
Yeah.
- Vlog, you just witnessed a
very exciting moment for me.
Babin's been getting the huge benefit of
you know, the anti D-Rock propaganda
that I'm so passionate about.
But we just witnessed
the first moment where
he's substantially dropped the ball,
and came up with an excuse.
Tyler's struggled with this at times,
but he's been a lot better now.
He just owns it.
But we just watched Babin try to
come up with some horse shit excuse.
And I'm, I'm enjoying this because
it was a really fun moment.
I hope he edits this and
shows the whole thing
from where I ask him,
I hope he recalls it,
I don't know if he was filming yesterday
when I asked him to actually do it.
As some of you know I
did a caption contest
to pick a winner.
I asked Babin 'cause he
had, oh I don't know,
ungodly amounts of down time yesterday,
to help me scale the execution.
He did not. Dropped
the ball. Solid fumble.
When I asked him about it right now,
he had a funny little face.
I wish I had a camera on him,
thought for a second
of where he should go.
He went down the excuse tunnel,
which is the tunnel for losers.
So, we're gonna make this
little video right now,
and this is gonna help a lot of you
and it's gonna help Babin.
We're not gonna let that fly.
We're gonna call him out on
it publicly, to all of you.
We're gonna move on our merry way
and you know, it's been addressed,
and, it's an L, it's a micro loss,
but on a macro he's a great kid
and he's doing great work.
And having fun if we can address it today,
and we'll move on and
next time he might just,
you know Tyler I've watched now
and be like, no that's on me.
At first you liked to do
the excuses too Tyler.
That shit probably played
with AJ a little bit.
But, you know, we've now kind of gotten,
you're good now at being
like that's my L, right?
- Yep. And I've learned.
- And, and maybe you can encourage
Babin a little bit later.
- He, picked it up pretty quick.
- Well he still hasn't picked it up, like,
- But,
- We're forcing him
into it right now, we'll,
we'll see if he picks it up.
(laughter)
Yo, it's a midday update.
Babin hasn't done much,
but I on the other hand
has completely crushed a bunch
of inner sports meetings,
bunch of client meetings for Vayner Media,
been focused as fuck.
Nothing super glamorous. No keynotes.
No fucking selfies on the street.
Just fucking CEO life, trying to get it.
(groovy music)
I've left money on the
table my whole life.
- Yeah.
(groovy music)
- Just heading into another
meeting here in Hollywood.
Hollywood keeps calling.
And I'm not answering.
(laughter)
So good right?
(groovy music)
Just had a meeting with Jimmy Iovine.
And here's what he had to say.
I'm sorry I have to do it to you.
- The only reason why
I'm doing this is because
I may be able to do
this with my headphones.
- I love it.
Just one, I mean look,
- Yes.
- You're a fucking legend to every
single fucking kid watching this.
- Mhm.
- What core belief of what allows them
to get to where they wanna be?
- Be willing to work
harder than the next guy.
Take a next person.
Take more pain than the next
person and just don't stop.
- Eat shit.
- And don't quit.
That's it, and if you're not doing that,
you're gonna finish second or third.
- Legend life.
- Picture?
- Yes of course.
- I'm from the Philippines
and I saw your Vlog with Will.
- Renee, nice to meet you.
- Thank you.
- Let's take a picture. Yeah.
- She is so excited.
- Thank you so much.
- You're welcome, nice to meet you.
- Oh my god, I'm so happy.
(laughter)
- Bye, nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- Take care, have fun bye bye.
- Doing a Gary, I'm taking
all the photos out here.
Nice to meet you man.
- Pleasure man.
Thanks for having me.
- Yeah, no doubt.
- I'm excited.
- Come on in.
- Thank you, thank you, thank you.
- This is my laptop.
- Gary.
- Chris.
- Big fan,
- Thank you brother.
- Nice to meet you.
- Thanks for the love.
- What's up man? Chris. Nice to meet you.
- The lighting, the lighting is serious.
You guys did it right.
Like I know what my comfort zone is,
and I'm comfortable with that.
But I also really understand
why people need to go their way
and that's the, that's
the fucking thing man.
Like don't do it the way I'm doing it,
but just do it your way
and don't fucking judge
other people's way.
- Interesting.
See I feel like I'm kind of at
a strange crossroads in my life
where I feel like my life,
- Because you know
you're about to explode.
- I'm, I'm, kind of.
- Long, long, long.
Thank you, like, like I, he, listen.
The man's about to explode, some are gonna
be upset about it, others gonna be pumped
'cause you've been there from the get.
You're about to explode.
The singular reason I'm here,
- Here we go.
- Is because I'm collecting people that
understand what the fuck is going on.
And the list is short.
- Hmm.
- You understand what's, that's it.
Like I don't know what else to say,
that's the fucking punch line,
see ya, goodnight.
Like that's the fucking thing.
So yeah, you're at an
interesting crossroads
'cause you're about
fucking 15 seconds away
from shit getting really ridiculous,
and you're gonna be fucking
crippled by options,
and you and Mr. Long over here
are gonna have to make some decisions,
and the fucking variables
are gonna fucking go
in a hundred different directions.
And you got some fucking
decisions to make.
- Sure.
- Thank you for having me.
- No jumper. Coolest podcast in the world.
Check us out on YouTube,
Soundcloud, iTunes,
Gary motherfucking D.
- Yeah.
- Check off the list
(pounding the table)
We out.
(headphones hitting table)
Beautiful. Out into the world.
They're gonna be sitting right there.
- Let's rock.
- Alright let's go.
Adam,
(hand clap)
I really appreciate it man.
Thank you for the hospitality.
- Can't believe you were
interviewing with Freak.
- That went well, right?
- That was awesome.
(hand clap)
Thank you so much.
- Take care bro.
What up?
(hands slap)
- Good man.
- How are you man?
- I'm good, I'm good.
- 'Sup?
What's your name?
- Elliott.
- Nice to meet you.
- Yeah, what up man? Gary.
- Lugo, it's nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- Never thought I'd run into you here.
- I'm glad we did man, I'm glad.
(hands slap)
- Just came from out of Connecticut,
I'm a, I'm a business owner.
- Yes sir. Get it.
- I look up to your, I
watch all your stuff.
- I appreciate it brother.
Thank you so much.
- All that shit's so
motivating, yeah, no problem.
- Thank you.
- It's great meeting you.
- Thank you man, take care of yourself.
See ya Lugo.
- See ya man.
(traffic)
- Like, that's such a good part of L.A.
(laughter)
I don't wanna leave.
- I know, I know, I know.
- I love this street.
You know? Fuck.
(chatter)
- But,
- But we gotta go.
- We gotta go.
- You know guys, it looks like Babin's
probably not gonna make this flight.
Which is gonna mean 0 for 2
for my film crew to Australia.
There's some sort of weird jinx on that,
we're about to find out.
I don't think Bobby gets on.
That's his nickname.
Great day, huge, huge,
huge, execution in L.A.
I'm happy about that.
We'll see ya later.
(groovy music)